one of the because I love about you is
you're always so good at like consoling
people oh I love a good home oh don't
you love it come on oh babe but it's
like it's a lot closeness
oh it's lingering as well I like it
[Music]
walkabout to climb with me Josh Smith
and today we're joined by the queen of
the power C I'm loving and passing my
intro you are now designing collection
for NEX yeah the vibe
it's a funny old thing because I'm not a
fashion designer obviously and next and
I've worked together for a couple of
years and and I didn't edit for them so
they said we need to come him like pick
your favorite bits and all that jazz and
I went yeah okay
one of the first fittings I ever did
Charlotte who's in the corner short into
my house and I just kind of stood there
in my knickers and bra I think I went
I'd love to do a range of pajamas behind
it kind of started with that and I
proceeded to go upstairs and chill the
pajamas out my drawer that I loved I was
like you know like something like this
and that feel like that and accessible
to all people and and she was like as
first time I met you okay they went okay
let's kind of let's explore this job but
how about you don't want to do a little
capsule collection and you design like
the pieces that you've always wanted in
your wardrobe and I do to be in your
underwear when you got guests around the
house it's very easy to be around how do
you describe the collection if you say
classic pieces that last and that you
can mix and match like this shirt on the
pajamas I want to wear as a shirt for me
I've always said that if I'm comfortable
in clothes I feel more confident hence
the power suits what's really amazing
about what you're doing this station
your crew is well especially like
delivering babies is you're really
bringing out their everyday power of
everyday women and I think that's such
an important thing to do because I think
sometimes that's really is that st.
really important to you I think what was
important for me was to highlight the
job that they do because I had seen my
mom do it for such a long time and I
knew how hard she worked and it was also
a job that I thought I would do because
that is what I believed my path in life
gonna be till this weird thing happened
you know I'm very lucky that I get to do
things like the clothing line with next
and go and work in the hospital and live
the
line in I thought I would always have
yes I'm getting to dip into my alternate
universe really but also have this
really fun day job where I go and just
read words on telly and be silly and sit
down and interview people yeah oh you're
doing it to me the way I grew up
things like this don't didn't really
ever happen to people like me so it all
feels a bit like make the most of it way
yeah I kind of have to have a real
genuine love for something otherwise I
feel like it looks like I'm a bit of a
fraud or faked or something you know has
to be real as a powerful woman on TV
from starting out the beginning your
career to now how have you seen like the
positioning of women on TV change I
suppose I feels like there's more women
around now I've when I think back to
when I used to watch telly when I was
younger I don't think I can really come
up with as many kind of female females
as I can males from a behind-the-scenes
point of view I feel like the teams are
made up of much more women now like in
the beginning it seems like it was it
was quite male-dominated the voice for
example when it was on the BBC and now
it's on ITV it's pretty much all run by
women and I'm like it's it's really nice
yeah because I think the initial the the
automatic default setting is oh I bet
that's a [ __ ] environment yeah it's I
actually it's not they're all bloody
lovely and is it bit shiori's women just
happy to talk yes you know to mean let's
talk about a little bit more I think
it's also a really important thing you
just said about the bitchiness saying is
that there's still like these this
everyday sexism that goes on yeah
because I bet so beep in case you like
babe you're you work you're a mother
how do you do it like and that question
itself is kind of sexist because you
never really ask men that no why do you
get asked that question a lot yeah
how do I don't I do it with a lot of
help and a lot of people don't have
perhaps oh how do they do it
I mean that is the real question but no
I don't matter gets all the child care
out because I leave them at school and
forget well yeah that dance for tonight
what's you go to me number I'm a jumper
oh you're like
yeah I'm I'm my pogo stick cuz I don't
really have much rhythm I just jump so
you might be doing straight any time
seeing them better I'd love to so I've
always wanted to do strictly but at the
same time I'm terrified too yeah because
do you not have a great singing voice
yeah when I'm drunk at karaoke I think
that's it I'm jump on Jovie like I mean
I give it my all and I'm like actually
that's and then that goes because my top
tip for karaoke is always get the
audience advance I always do a Spice
Girls song so I'm like boy climb it to
the left I'm like there any spice boys
in the house so you're always still
always hosting yeah and then that was
like God that was such a great perform
it's like today I'm gonna try that next
try that next maybe tonight oh my god
yes for more epic videos with such epic
people as Emma Willis get ahead where
you supposed to climb at UK channels
boom
[Music]